well I told you yesterday that it was
likely to happen soon and it actually
happened minutes after we finished
producing yesterday's show Senator
Kamala Harris has officially dropped out
of the presidential primary she
collapsed in the polls over the last few
months and as I told you yesterday
Kamala Harris had qualified for the next
debate which is the sixth debate I think
on December 19th
but the polling was just not there her
fundraising was just not there and I'll
tell you I respect her decision to drop
out at this point in time I'm gonna
address that more in a moment let's look
at her polling first you will see that
despite hitting a national polling high
of about 15% this is her high she wasn't
leading but her campaign high was about
15% that was in the first half of July
it's just been downhill for her all the
way down to a national average of barely
3% in recent weeks now Kamala is not
someone that I was supporting she has a
very troubling record in the criminal
justice system during her time as the
Attorney General of California
she was slippery on health care to say
the least she definitely brought some
clever planned attacks to the debates
she had one on Joe Biden in the first
debate she put together an attack on
Tulsi Gabbard at the last one but it
wasn't the sort of substance have been
inspiring candidacy that did anything
for me particularly her slipperiness on
health care she wrote in an email to her
campaign supporters to her campaign
newsletter quote my campaign for
president simply doesn't have the
financial resources we need to continue
I'm not a billionaire
I can't fund my own campaign and as the
campaign has gone on it's become harder
and harder to raise the money we need to
compete in good faith I can't tell you
my supporters and volunteers that I have
a path forward if I don't believe I do
so to you my supporters it is with deep
regret but also with deep gratitude that
I am suspending my campaign today now
she's absolutely correct and that's what
gets us back to the respect thing Kamala
Harris qualified for the next debate but
she dropped out anyway
because she has no chance that is what I
respect because most candidates who have
no shot would keep going clogging up the
debate stages because they want FaceTime
they want the publicity she realizes she
can't win she realizes she's not raising
the money she needs implicit in that
also is that she doesn't have the
polling support that would allow her to
raise that money and so she's dropping
out and I respect the fact that she's
going to clear the clear clear the stage
and not plug it up with folks that don't
have a path to victory now there's a
whole bunch of other people who should
do the same thing and we'll see if
anybody else does between now and
December 19th immediate questions about
this number one is Kamala Harris angling
for a VP spot don't know too early to
talk about and quite frankly I'm not
super interested in talking about VP
stuff yet
number two who will she support or
endorse unclear there's the idea that
for demographic reasons maybe it would
be Elizabeth Warren there's the idea
that because of policy because she's
more of a centrist it could be Joe Biden
I don't think there's too many people
thinking that she would endorse Bernie
Sanders but you never know a more
immediate question is where does her
support go I actually don't think it's
that important of a question she was
polling three point four percent on
average as of yesterday when she decided
to drop out every candidate if they drop
out their support would be divided among
the remaining candidates it's not gonna
go all to one candidate and however you
slice and dice three point four percent
it's not really going to be a
game-changer so I'm not super interested
in where does Connell is three point
four percent go but overall the field is
thinning I believe at this point that's
a good thing lots of the people left
don't have a shot at the nomination
they're not in the running in any of the
first four primary states nor are they
getting any traction beyond two or three
percent nationally it's too late in the
game to be clogging up the debate stage
when there are real differences between
the candidates that have a shot I
welcome a thinning of the debate stage
and we will see if it continues let me
know not only what you think of Kamala
bailing but more
importantly who else should bail before
the next debate I want to hear from you
leave a reply if you're watching on
YouTube we'll have a post about this on
our Instagram page at david pakman show
follow us there and leave me your
thoughts there as well
I am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka Steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli nki st.com
/p a que ma n